[Music]
hey
hey
hey
culture's famous mom and dad had some
fun at her lavish third birthday bash
on Tuesday cardi B shared this clip
wearing a skin-tight pink latex dress
that showed off her sweet baby bump
dancing on her rapper hubby offset
[Music]
cardi who is currently pregnant with her
second child captioned the slo-mo clip
quote big mama oh yes honey the mommy
Daddy dance went down at their little
girls over the top princess inspired
birthday party
happy
happy birthday
happy birthday
the party included a horse-drawn
princess carriage and a castle a giant
storybook a table fit for a queen a ball
pit lots and lots and lots of balloons
and Animal Farm real life Disney
Princesses oh
what is that is
and a crab leg Tower
wow and it wouldn't be a princess party
without a cake Regal right so what did
offset and cardi get for culture for her
special day
[Music]
Yep this three-year-old got Iced Out the
piece featured five charms shaped like
an Hermes Birkin bag a Chanel logo
Minnie Mouse a bow wrapped heart and a k
initial for culture of course wow
cardi recently revealed she and offset
are expecting their second child
together during her performance at the
BET Awards and the proud parents shared
the moment they got a look at their new
little bundle of joy I'm about to see
her stinkable
cardi also shared these beautiful
maternity photos of her growing family
on Instagram there's some big big things
on the way big things and when it comes
to family it seems cardi has always
known she wants a big one in 2019 the
New York native told E.T she was ready
to give culture some siblings
what does it mean to be a mother
it means everything it's it's like a
feeling that it's undescribable it's
like love joy it's a switch you know
what I'm saying it's like automatic
smile it's always everything so if one
brings you this much joy would you
double the joy
I want to have more kids you do yeah
more kids that sounds like many
[Music]
you know how whatever my body could take
I feel like the more my baby grows I see
like the different levels
and this is gonna be different levels
all the time from one year old
to going around chasing them making sure
they don't put things in their mouth to
you know five-year-old when they start
going to school learning things
interacting with other kids it's always
going to be different levels yeah yeah
of course all right well we're waiting
on the next few
[Music]
foreign